JENNY BROWN: This week, we're
talking about everything I/O,
Tensor processing, and more.
Welcome to This Week in
Cloud, where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
Last week was I/O, and we're
I-Overwhelmed with cool Google
things to show off.
If you're looking for
one convenient place
to find all the cloud
updates, head on
over to the Google Cloud blog.
We've compiled all
the announcements
and noteworthy
news into one post
full of useful information,
like exactly what's changing
and why it matters
for developers.
Plus you can check out the
Google developer's blog
to read more about the other
areas, like Chrome and Android.
Here are some of our favorites.
You may already be familiar
with Tensor processing units,
the chip that we
built specifically
to speed up the development
of ML applications.
Well, now we're giving
you access to TPU v2
and v3 pods in beta.
TPU pods are like a
supercomputer of TPUs
strapped together
and running jobs
in hours that used
to take weeks.
Read more about what they
do, and try using one
in the interactive collab.
From startup to
enterprise, Firebase
is all about making mobile and
web app development easier.
And we saved some
big announcements
for I/O. Major
improvements to the ML Kit
bring the power of Google's
ML expertise to your app
through APIs like
on-device translation.
Firebase Performance
Monitoring lets
you see how to visualize where
your web apps may be slowing
down, while the updated
Audience Builder helps
you make smarter decisions
for your user base.
Read more about the details,
and build some amazing user
experiences.
Everyone wants to make great
predictions with their data,
but you can't do that
without preparing it first.
If you want to
transform your data
without using complex systems,
look no further than Data Prep.
We've got a new blog post that
looks at how to use Data Prep,
and gives you an idea of
a three-step data quality
workflow, from assessing your
data set to resolving issues
and validating at scale.
Follow along with the example,
or open up the console
and try it out on your own data.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.